we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we're back we're hacks we're doing
it back to the bar we got a japanese
whiskey we got a japanese fetish and we
got our old pal
sal volcano everybody let him hear it
japanese sal dude
we would not have tried this if not for
you did you get centauri we didn't get
it uh matt peters are incredible you
texted me what do you drink i'm like
tequila vodka whiskey but like i'm like
don't get anything from wait why
japanese whiskey uh i like irish and
japanese whiskey the best that's all
i've never tried this just the taste of
you know i don't love like uh tennessee
whiskey or really
apparently very classy can i get a we
might be drunk glass on the website
you got merch already well we got this
is our first step with uh oh we might be
drunk glass we might be drunkpod.com is
that right okay we got bottle openers we
got
all kinds of stuff kidding me look at
the picture behind you
look at that i seen the clips but
you don't get a scope of it oh it's a
scope
spaceball's the movie spaceball's the
flame thrower
you gotta
we even have tongs you have tongues and
you have the ice the ball ice
the ball ice is [ __ ] cool what
happened to cisco
the thong song yeah this is the man he
made 100 million dollars and did he
don't did he though 100 million at least
20 million he was in 112 as well which
was another r b group i don't know one
he split from them but he was
for a moment there cisco was a part of
all of our lives of course i mean i was
in spring break time when that came out
it was really oh geez i was way off
that's dude that says you have
that's not accurate okay that's not
accurate i know that's not accurate
because because mine's not accurate then
that means he's got
40 45 dollars in the bank oh really
no he's not if it says 6 million but you
don't hear from him anymore this is what
i'm saying how when people aren't that
much in the limelight and then they are
ghosted yes like what is he doing what's
his day-to-day school called a one-hit
wonder for i mean look where's the mambo
number five guy yeah lubega there you go
yeah he's doing casinos come on throw
another one
he opens with that song he's in deep
trouble
i did uh what do you do after that
they're just like i what now
two times in my life did i throw in a
five and play a song 18 times at a bar
the first time i ever did it was white
wedding at a bar in green point at about
five in the morning a girls fight broke
out there was there was dogs in there it
was crazy
yeah she said meet me at diamonds [ __ ]
diamonds was a strip club nearby i'll
never forget it there was no register
they had all the money in a cigar box
wow yeah and you had to knock on the
door they slid it open and they let you
in what year was it 73
i'll tell you this was early 2000's oh
those were the days yeah yeah white
wedding white wedding and
and and it it it played over and over
and over and people were like by the
fifth or sixth time people were getting
antsy yeah and then i did it another
time at a place in in green point that
was you know fourth green and i played
mama number five oh nice you gotta play
one that's gonna
get them going yeah that's really fun
for one but
cruel for six or seven yeah this is the
mullany bit the uh it is and when he did
that i was like [ __ ] i was like
ah that's i'll talk about that what do
you do what's new
yeah
yeah that is the perfect one i will say
my real life thing happened before that
i got accused of stealing my laney joke
when i first started and i had a youtube
video thank god with the date on it
which one
it was a joke about how uh chinese
restaurants sound like slurs okay you
know like uh you know those [ __ ]
golden noodles yeah yeah these panda
kings
and i got a ton of [ __ ] and i just
showed people to youtube and they just
don't respond you're like how about a
sorry how about oh i was wrong right but
you know that's no it's more about the
way it's more about their anger exactly
youtube commenters rarely are like i
made a mistake you know what do you
think of it oh wait oh i haven't tried
it yet yeah it's good it's not what i
was expecting
oh
wait
it is heatier than i thought it would be
yeah there are there are different
i i'll
text you when i get home i'll text you
the one that's like american scotch oh
not american scotch that was the dumbest
thing i've ever said totally sure are
americans
yeah it tastes like scotch it doesn't
taste like what i mean i guess it's all
whiskey but you do you guys
taste like half a
you guys uh how how much do you really
tie on
well we do a couple in a day i know you
met me for dinner last week and you were
ossified by the time you got to well we
did ari's pod yeah and we got after it
okay that was not good yeah for an old
man arie can he's got grandpa's cough
medicine he's going out
well everyone the same things they
regret on podcasts we figure why half
acid
let's go all in right yeah we did the
rogan compilation in one pod
but yeah no i was i definitely had a few
in me when i saw you i hope i was on my
best behavior no that was funny
that we had dinner when's the last time
you went out for dinner with your
friends we never do work
it's nice i know but you got to remember
isn't it crazy like you were pretty
sloshed for this dinner apparently that
used to be my whole life every night was
just a drunken blur all the time go to
dinner go to a party like oh remember
that party we went to that second party
actually i don't remember the second
party that was my whole life and now we
do that maybe once every six months
absolutely yeah have you slowed down a
lot oh god yeah i don't get drunk really
i'm saying it's like a couple times
a week ago by accident
i got drunk at us the last time i got
really drunk was uh by accident at a
skank's pod oh yeah it was the first one
i had done in a couple of years it was
like after the pan i guess probably like
maybe eight nine months ago
i was drinking whiskey meat and it was
down easy didn't eat that day snuck up
on me by the end of it i was blackout
there you go they called the pot i was
throwing up in a garbage pail and at the
stand wow yeah and then jay had to drive
me home wow
i don't know what happened maybe someone
put something in my drink i don't know
what the [ __ ] well with that i don't put
it past those guys yeah
that is a joke it's weird like you get
surprised drunk now like that used to
never happen like you drink because you
don't want to be a surprise this is
legal i know what i'm putting in my body
yeah it's not like an edible true like
what the [ __ ] but now as an adult you
get surprised drunk sometimes yeah yeah
good point before you were like when am
i gonna be drunk come on come on you
wanted to get drunk so badly
now sometimes when i'm like all right
i'll try to have a couple of drinks and
then it doesn't take it's the worst
thing where you drink like two or three
drinks or something like that nothing's
taken yes and you're like what am i
supposed to do now i'm supposed to put
it into overdrive has seven eight drinks
exactly or but it's a waste yeah
because you want the buzz but you're not
getting it and now you're just getting
the toxins so then you wake up hung over
you're like i didn't even have a buzz
terrible terrible no weed no no
i do edibles now to sleep okay
the funniest way to like we're adults we
do drugs for our health yeah that's so
weird i will i'll take a five mil uh
indica to go to sleep yeah it helps out
like a life for the whole night fun
dreams too and i tried everything i
tried all the ambience and the zoloft
and the the the fentanyl
nothing really worked but
but this weed works mark's joking he did
do fentanyl yeah this is the stopping
one accident on accident by accident
is there a reasonable dose
no well
you guys are you guys are [ __ ] with
me no i didn't i wish i was what would
you mean you did
it yeah mark thought it was like cbd
he's like i'll do the good part of the
fentanyl right here no mark took cbd
from a stranger thinking it was
something else well i needed a xanax i
kind of had a rough week
and it was fentanyl or laced all right
let's let's stop let's back it up i'm
sorry for doing this i feel like i just
got into trouble with dad oh no are you
in trouble we'll see
i have some if you need me
wait he said it was a stranger explain
the context you were on the road or
something i was on the road it was the
host of a show and i said he goes you
need anything you know he's he's calling
me i was like well i'll do uh some
granola bars maybe some jerky some
tequila and if he got any xanax i just
can't sleep i'm dying here and he goes i
gotcha and turns out he was an ex-addict
yeah the first bad sign was he had a
pager
wait so he told you he was giving you
cbd and you did not know zannah i don't
know where you guys got cbd xanax was
the pill that i thought i was taking
that i asked for and then he gave it to
me and i think it had some fentanyl in
it because i was out for like 24 hours
oh my god i fell asleep in the hotel
they had to come in the guy like shook
me the the what do you call it the maid
shook me and then they just put me in
the lobby because they had to clean the
room they pulled mark up in a rug
you didn't know prior what was in it no
i just popped it how did you find out
after well then i woke up in the lobby
at about 3 p.m and it was a red roof inn
so i was uh i was one of four guys
passed out i found a used used still hot
crack pipe in my room at a red ridge get
out of here did you hit it was that no
we did not took a photo of it walked
across the street went to a holiday inn
express yeah you got i really got to get
a free room with a with a crap i
wouldn't even stay there i didn't want
to stay there yeah i said guys i don't
think this looks shady we went in and
then i didn't my buddy had it he came
out with a crack pie i said can we go
now and he let me go how do you miss a
crack pipe when you're cleaning unless
it was the maid doing it also what what
a shitty crack head
you forget the the pipe yeah they're not
a reliable black and like smokey i know
but those are supposed to be addictive
aren't they i guess it was empty highly
addictive you imagine that what happened
wait i got to get back though you wake
up a day later you don't know what
happened no you call him
no guys thank you for being on we might
be drunk my podcast
yeah i know right the tables
uh basically my friend we were supposed
to go tubing that day my opener so he
came by he's like you have an answer
what a juxtaposition i know right the
drug that'll kill you in a heartbeat and
then just just fun fun childhood times
that's why i needed sleep i want to be
ready with the tube for the sunshine
and uh yeah so he goes uh i just came to
the hotel out of instinct and oh he
called the front desk because he's like
this guy's not answering his phone can
you call his room like what room
that room he checked out wait a minute
does he have curly hair and a bad act
yeah
that was me he's just sitting in the
lobby and he came to you so he came to
the hotel and he said he dragged me
around and like went we went to the
bodega down the street and my feet were
dragging and he's like oh he bought me a
lemonade a water you know just trying to
get some fluids in me i'm out the whole
time weekend at norman's yes
he's doing your ass
[Laughter]
so when did it come out that he gave you
fentanyl well so then i wouldn't wake up
we had two shows that night sold out in
san antonio and he's like you got to get
up and he called my girlfriend he called
my agent and he's like i don't know what
to do like we got to cancel these shows
this guy won't wake up and so he had a
bright idea and he goes
i've seen people do this i'm getting the
iv lady the iv lady shows up
in the hotel
gives us both ivs i filmed the whole
thing i was wrecked out of my mind i'll
show you the video i'm a mess i'm on
another planet he put you there
oh no there's a different opener oh that
was the host this is the open okay so
the feature
so he's helping he's a guy i know the
host i didn't know okay and uh i get the
ivs and i kind of start coming back to
life and we go to the show and i did
them
did you the host was there the next
night did he say something new i said
what the hell was that he goes oh that's
the good stuff
yeah [ __ ] you idiot
i already scolded them for an entire
episode for this that that could have
had a different ending oh yeah we love
you here you know and we might be drunk
we love you
around for a long long time well the
worst part is that guy hosted for bob
saget
we got to the bottom of it i couldn't i
had to get out of it but what what human
being with with half a brain when
someone says can i get a xanax just
holds off and gives you the hardest drug
that he he's risking your life yeah what
human being asked a complete stranger
for a dream right you know what you're
right the trouble started here but it's
a it's a legal drug it's a prescription
but it's not a drug
or heroin yeah but it's a prescription
drug
touche not a dude who's got 10 minutes
in [ __ ] san antonio yeah
but wait a minute i'm not even sure it
was fentanyl in my defense oh so it was
something about what it was no so you
just left it a mystery yeah he said
that's the good stuff and you'd stop you
questioning right there i think i said
was there fentanyl in that he goes i
don't think so but i can get that if you
want it so this guy was the real dude
what nino brown used to tell people
that's the good stuff
yeah goodness yeah yeah that was kind of
horrifying it was scary have you asked
for a pill or an
you learned your lesson yeah all right
you i mean you don't you drink and you
do you smoke weed and that's it that's
it yeah oh i i recently did shrooms for
the first time in my life i've done it
twice in my life only it's the best i
know you do you do it all the time i've
heard your stories from fans yeah i i
you know i just before i got too old
voiced you know
i just was like i gotta try this you
know before and i and i did and the
first time i did it wow i'm not
condoning it don't do it i'm not telling
anyone to do it but it was fun i'm
condoning do it yeah it's great it was
fun i i i think i got a friend what's
that with friends i was with friends
good you got it and uh and i had just a
perfect experience it didn't go too far
but it went i i i didn't see i didn't
hallucinate or anything but i saw like
it was almost like everything was moving
and like everything comes alive yeah and
i know i'm on it you know so i wasn't
scared i didn't go down any weird like
you know holes or anything like that
that's a myth and and i it was just it
was fun the entire night i got a little
allergic reaction to the mushrooms okay
i got a little flush which i never had
before but i fought through that yeah
and it was really fun i always hear you
talking about like the throw up phase
yeah so i was worried about that but it
didn't happen okay i tried to recreate
it a few months later and i was told by
ari that you don't want to do it too
close to each other because they won't
it won't take sure by the way i love
that ari is also like the drug whisperer
he roofied bert
what makes him the he this is the but he
does have a website about mushrooms
about how to do them yes he's exactly
weirdly the one who's one like just do
mushrooms with me and it'll be okay yeah
and i do kind of trust him yeah he's the
guy to do it with really oh yeah oh yeah
well he just knows so much about it he
can get the right kind he can talk you
down if you have weird thoughts he's
he's an expert okay he wasn't there the
first time and i laid all the mushrooms
out on a paper towel and i took a
picture and i sent him i said tell me
how much of this to do and he told me
then the next time he was with me
and we grinded it in like a coffee
grinder into a fine dust and put it in
our iced tea
it was a whole bunch of people and uh
that's scary no way to get the first
time didn't even nothing nothing moved
nothing a loose name interesting it was
it was a dud i hate it because you're
looking for it the whole is that it yeah
it might trigger but not now you got to
build you're like all right we're doing
this like people yeah
yeah it was a whole thing like this is
going to be all night we have this
experience together and then it was a
dud damn did you ever do that in high
school you ever take an edible like uh
oh and it hits you when you're in a
class and you're like [ __ ] whoa i never
did at school yeah no never in my life i
didn't really smoke until 2018. wow yeah
i i i hate that then i as a kid i like
yeah now i'm like now it doesn't do
anything for you
it does it does stuff but it's bad stuff
just yeah but you got to you got to just
take the right puff for the right amount
and it could kind of just kind of tried
a million different puffs
it's not working for me it takes the
edge off sometimes i write on it you
know oh i could never yeah i know some
people do that but i'm not one of them
no i'm with you though like i take it to
sleep and it helps but if i don't fall
asleep then the bad [ __ ] thc or you do a
little bit of thc like five milligrams
of a gummy i'll just
you know just a nibble and uh if it if
it works i go to bed if i don't go to
bed
bad time all bets are off yeah you're
just running running around bad stuff
bad memories you suck yeah you're gonna
fail what are you doing he's sitting
there
sitting in a seat just not moving just
thinking about it are you trying to do
something you're throwing on a movie
you're listening to music well the movie
will trigger it'll be like oh this thing
happened in the movie i'm like oh yeah
remember that what about that oh yeah
and then now we're in a wormhole right
yeah if i if death if death i start
thinking about death then that's all i'm
going to think about
yeah i feel like that's man i'm in
therapy for death
for death yeah you think about death a
lot yeah really my whole life
it's bad here's my thing it's a bad way
to live covey did not help yeah not even
me i'm my loved ones and all that stuff
and it just did not help i had to like
but here's the thing with death i get it
it's inevitable though so you might as
well accept it but are you scared to get
hit by a bus kind of death no you're
scared of the big sleep at the moment
when is it going to be oh come on like
i'm gonna leave this dirt to leave my
loved ones i'm more scared you gotta be
50 years to be truthful it's more about
my parents
but they're going to die before you yeah
he's scared of their death
they are
good
amazing
good point yeah you told me like i
didn't assume
i thought you meant you were going to
leave them oh no i got you okay yeah no
i and then and then god forbid like a
tragic death
like someone before that time type of
thing
it's all the same caboose i start
thinking of it everything's packed into
the same luggage and i'm unpacking and i
just it's uh
it's i talk about it i talk about it
weekly how often do you go to therapy
weekly weekly no i i did for a for a
while i did and then i stopped and i did
up during i i did again about three
years ago i started going again i would
go actually right by uh right on six
right by the celery i know you guys all
share the same
yeah i went to a woman uh helped me so
much i did emdr have you done this i've
heard of this neil brennan did it it's
uh he did and he did it by
recommendation of the person who told me
to do it oh okay and it it actually
worked tell the people at home what that
is it's basic
do i look over there i'm i'm doing an
audience
i picture it it's a form of therapy
where you uh you disassociate trauma
from triggering in your mind and you do
that oddly but it's a
number of things can do it like you you
go through the stepping they make you
think of things and then there's
multiple ways one i held i held these
two things in my hands that would
alternately vibrate
and there's a pattern to it and so you
think of this you close your eyes you
think and it vibrates and it's doing
something it's detaching you some people
do it about following like your eyes
follow something or there's different
ways to do it yeah but uh
someone sang its praises i went i had i
had some issues that i needed to clear
up and it it did it i couldn't believe
it so now i'm going to start do i
haven't been doing the mdr for the death
yet but i'm going to start that now whoa
damn so you think it's some childhood
trauma that some trauma in there
although it's an understandable fear i
mean it is as mark said it's an
inevitable fear so i get that yeah i
mean it's not like a fear that like a
therapist could be like no you have
nothing to worry about therapists like
yeah you're gonna die yeah but that's
why i don't fear it because i'm like
it's coming anyway why worry about it i
remember my friend got a he was a drug
addict and he got put in jail and he
kept calling us from jail and i kept
being like are you nervous about getting
beat up or the shower rape what are you
freaking out and he's like i'll worry
about that when it happens now i'm just
want to get out oh and i was like i'd be
worried he put his hands on two things
they were different though
still shaking
it's more my
parents it's more that kind of got it
got it yeah that is scary but again it's
also crazy that's happened to every
single human being yeah i know and i say
that to myself but i think it's like
before and after like and then you know
how old are you 38 okay so i'm 45. i i
only i really really went into overdrive
like in the last few years and
especially with covert but you for the
first time in my life right now i
actually feel a little old and i never
did before oh really you got a full head
of hair yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i just yeah but i just feel
the oh i feel i feel uh removed
from a little bit like like removed from
like the [ __ ] that's going on today i
don't like it yeah i don't like the
music i don't like the style i like to
do this i'm like i don't like i don't
like [ __ ]
social media i don't like the digital
age i don't like tic-tac-toe i don't
like any of that stuff but then you sit
there and go is that me being out of
because socrates said this i know too i
mean it's completely it's reciprocal and
cyclical and all that stuff whatever it
is and i and i know that too and i'm
like well here it is here it is it
actually ends up you hear about it you
see it you hear people older people talk
to you about it you you just don't feel
it you acknowledge it you don't feel it
i've recently started to feel it and it
was like [ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah i guess
that's what they call a midlife crisis i
don't know oh yeah i don't know it just
happens and also i started to see the
age on my parents a little bit right i
haven't so everything now is becoming a
little bit like
that the pandemic did that because we
all saw our folks a little less yeah so
yeah it did that and i think we all got
worn down a little bit by it sure and so
i don't know i just started feeling it
and i never felt that feeling before i'm
like oh this is what that feels like
it's not good it's like it's coming for
you well yeah it is it is never-ending
you know you know you we used to get
hung over i'd lose a day hung over when
you're in your 20s you're like ah man i
spent the whole day laying on the ground
puking now i'm like i lost a day
every day is precious what am i doing
life is going to end you can't we can't
waste a day being hungover you know if
you're hungover for a day you're lucky
if it doesn't leak into another day
you're so busy i mean you're one of the
most i mean that's probably why you feel
it dude you're probably exhausted you do
two podcasts you got your tv show and
practical jokers great show exploring we
love it but on top of that we're asking
you to do us a favor and come on the
podcast so i love this is i'm so happy
to be on this by the way
i love you both and i i like this i
haven't been able to do these lately and
i was like let me because you but you
must be exhausted don't you think that's
a big part of it i am i look in the
mirror and i look [ __ ] exhausted
every time i see someone they go wow you
look you look [ __ ] tired were you
doing something so if it's just it's
emanating from me like people just say
it to me now right yeah
and i do i feel [ __ ] tired and i and
i make sure i don't get drunk for that
reason nowadays it costs too much it
does and i and i and i get eight hours
seven men but i get my eight hours still
tired whoa it's mental it's all mentally
i do need to be in better shape and i'm
going to start working on that that'll
help too yoga let me just say this in
defense of the old man things i'm 38 and
i'm pushing 40. i i think about that too
i hate social media i hate to cancel i
hate all the [ __ ]
and then everybody goes oh every adult
says this this is classic standard
[ __ ] but you have to give us the
fact that we've
escalated
tenfold compared to what other
generations had with technology the
phone the internet exponentially right
so it's always whenever whenever right
now is always the most rapid it's going
yes so our whole lives it's only built
right and over end you're right we've
we've gone i i long for the old days oh
cause i sound like a peace and quiet do
i sound like an old man no simpler [ __ ]
dude you're 20 years from clinton
i'll take people waiting in an answering
machine yeah that's it yeah that was you
know i mean
you could avoid people what's that you
could avoid people get a voice
if someone texts you now and you don't
answer they know you saw it what's going
on
it's this thing you're on the hook on
for everything you know what i'm saying
it's just as we're talking about
technology mark's dumb phone
watch goes off oh yeah i also like i
also don't like all the information all
the time it's it's bad for us i mean
anxiety is up depression is up suicide
is up it ain't good and i think we're
going to look back on this in 20 years
and go that was the wild wild west what
was happening with the internet it's
like ronnie chang's joke you were on
twitter while you were pregnant you're
crazy such a great joke and it rings
true there's truth to that you used to
get the news the next morning in the
paper yeah and then i read it quietly
read it yeah you know and then it is it
is bad i realize how much i'm looking at
my phone i'm like oh this is so
addictive
it is that rush where you press like
loading loading loading nothing come on
yeah we want story we want buzz and we
should just stand the stop light turn
green we'd walk then it turned red and
we'd stand there now you're like i got a
minute you know i got 30 seconds i'll
check this i'll check that it's you ever
like put your phone away or something
and then like and then see how you react
like yeah you keep going forward you
keep going forward yeah and you'll and
they're like oh [ __ ] like you know what
i mean you would you would miss a toe
less if you were if you loaded out a bag
if you lost a toe you'd be like
you wouldn't do that with your you might
feel around for a second yeah your phone
it's that's a part of you yeah oh yeah
also there's no more conversation you
just look up the answer i would try to
do that like people are always like dude
that might happen at dinner i think well
people will be like oh like who is that
and everyone's like just picks their
phones up like wait wait wait put it
down yeah let's get it let's try it
again
and so we don't do we don't do that
exercise with our brains anymore either
i know i know dumbing down babe we're
dumbing down we're way dumbing down just
think like i'm moving
i'm just a i'm just a [ __ ] really
funny fun loving guest and i'm
there was no gps on your phone right so
i had to learn the trains i got i'd go
to queens on accident i go to brooklyn
accident
and and it makes your brain go where am
i i got to figure this out you ask a guy
am i on the right track and now i'm
interacting with human that's all over i
don't get in the car now without putting
on my gps a hundred percent of the time
even when i know where i'm going because
i want to know if there was an accident
and i should reroute there you go i put
it on every single time if i'm driving
10 minutes i put it on it's a lot of
information yeah this is what it feels
like in life now
you know when you go to a diner and it's
like here's the specials we got eggs
granola bacon and uh pancakes now a
diner menu is 38 pages long and you got
all these options and it's too much
cheesecake factory it's the cheesecake
factory it's too much none of the
options are that good there's a lot of
options but there's a lot of options
that's what life is netflix it's it's
you don't know what the [ __ ] to do
there's two good
shows there's 500 000 choices yeah
exactly there was seven stations
everyone knew every show we all got to
talk about remember what about
remembering phone numbers
i still remember a couple of childhood
nights
but you remembered who was important and
you you'd get up to a certain limit and
you'd you'd remember it that's over we
just lost our uh youth listenership on
this pocket
[ __ ] okay boom which i hate boomers
yeah but we hate everything yeah we're
just cliches right yeah hey gen z though
you would have a better life if you grew
up without a phone i swear to god i know
that's a bold statement but i'm so glad
i got i got to pee for you right now
uh-oh uh just generic sayings that are
regurgitated okay boomer uh let's go
brandon let's go brandon people you're
just trump is orange but from the other
side just be original or don't speak
yeah why are you speaking if it's
easy caring
that's another one there's a million of
them karen is like i'm really annoyed
because i did karen as a name and a joke
in a special like two years ago and now
people think i'm reaching for like the
karen i'm like no it was just the name i
used because it was a good name it was
in goodfellas come on karen [ __ ] up in
the head karen yeah yeah
yeah yeah the regurgitating is big we
might be drunk is excited to announce
our new sponsor indochino
tire looking like a schlub indochino is
here to get you looking and feeling like
a man about town in 2022
i just got some pants from there there's
some nice chinos navy beautiful fit like
a glove indochino is good because they
get your real sizes your real
measurements they go all in they want to
know exactly how you're tailored you
don't need to go to the tailor you don't
need to get the guy to go up your your
crotch there and tell you hang to the
left i already knew that thank you for
touching my genitals indochino does it
all online and they send you some good
stuff it's quality offers completely
custom fitted suits shirts casualwear
and more surprisingly at affordable
prices every piece is made to your exact
measurement and you can customize every
detail all online that's what i'm saying
choose everything about your suit
including the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings you can create a suit
that fits you and your style perfectly
the best part indochino suits start from
429 and shirts from 79 with all
customizations included that's a great
deal tell them how to get on it fatty
give yourself a style that sets the tone
for the rest of your year within
doshino drunk get fifty dollars off of
every purchase of 399 or more by using
promo code drunk at
indochino.com that's 50 off a purchase
of 399 or more that's nice indochino.com
that's n-i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code drunk support the
show you get 50 off any purchase of 399
or more by using promo code drunk at
indochino.com that's already a pretty
good deal hell of a deal we're getting
you a better deal yeah support the show
supporting doshino guys here here but
the other side of it it's great i mean
it's it's been amazing too i mean it's
true everyone concert tickets with a
couple of clicks i used to have to wait
online with a wristband porn i get it
are you ever in the water yeah i used to
have to go to bqe underneath the bqe
at
literally at one in the morning and like
walk in and be like hello i'm of age can
i get to the back that was the original
grinder
i hit the porn lottery uh pre-digital
age okay my boss that i worked for at a
pizzeria he was getting married and he
was the guy who held all of his friends
porn
so it was in a grande mozzarella cheese
box
this is like 40 year old virgin
box
yeah yeah yeah
vhs takes i'm going to call it i'll say
i'll call it 40 tapes in there wow
40 takes 40 ghs
[Music]
yeah
and uh he told me one day i'm getting
married i gotta get rid of this thing i
can't be the holder of it come to my
house i didn't know what i was walking
into he hands me a box of 40 tapes can
you believe that i had that thing for
years and years i was the guy i became
the guy for my friend right that's a
good man yeah and i remember the day i
had to get rid of it
yeah but it was it was we had passed it
uh
technology like we tested technologies
but it's crazy those 40 tapes now you're
just like click back
click back back then you have to just
manually be like this
what am i in the mood for yes now if
there's not a thumbnail i'm like what am
i even doing right right earned it these
eighth graders today they don't know how
good they have
but it's bad though because like you all
we all know i used to do a bit about how
like you i used to jerk off to jennifer
love he would smile and now it's like
you know it's harder but like that you
know these days it's hard
well it's like when you're young you do
that [ __ ] of course but then you get
older and and now it's this the pace is
just so much more rapid for these young
kids like oh you're opening with choke
porn
i know and that informs them
and then that's what they're doing it's
it's it's wild
sex today is not sex
women got [ __ ] the most not no pun
intended but it was like back in the day
you had to like charm a woman date a
woman like on the third date you might
not get laid now it's like hey lady i
can go on tinder and knock this out and
i don't know if that's good for
relationships
i like a lady who puts out don't get me
wrong but
if they hold out it's a different kind
of world expectation seems immediate now
there it is that's the best dan do you
know dan mintz he's hilarious
no one but i know i don't know him
either but he has some of my favorite
jokes yeah he has a joke you know you
guys sticks exactly in kids today they
don't know how good they have it with uh
with porn when i was young
i had to uh you know go to the sears
catalog and flip through until i found
something and nowadays kids just go
online you go to sears.com that's a
great show
that's great man he's had some smart
stuff yeah great misdirects he's now on
bob's burgers give give dan minty goog
damn yeah no it is it's gotten harder i
mean i mean i mean
you want to pace yourself
hopefully you live a long time if you if
you burn out and die at 32
go for it yeah but otherwise you're
gonna be 87 like what the [ __ ] are kids
going to be into i know you can't even
blame them because if it's right there
you're going to do it it's not but
here's my thing your parents leave out
dunkaroos in the cabinet exactly you're
eating dungaroos
i know fish is better if you give me
fentanyl i'm gonna take it
but
this is my theory it's a generational
thing look you got a hair metal you got
disco then it goes to hair metal then it
goes to grunge it's gotta keep changing
yeah i think maybe not this generation
but the next one is gonna be we're all
phones our parents use phones our
parents use social media they use the
internet we're almost amishy because
it's a pushback you gotta go the other
way maybe no i've never seen it
that's what i'm saying well you never
saw a trans person either before sure
you know so that was the only place you
used to see trans people that's true
isn't the porn that's a good point
i i will tell you i don't see people i
mean because they're only going to get
it's only going to get more and more
more and more access more and more
convenience more and more i don't know
how can it be more convenient oh it'll
get more convenient how though i don't
here's how it's going to get this crazy
where you know right now we're in our
airport they're just going to be like
how old is how old is robert de niro two
seconds boom but in the future it's
going to be
where are my shoes
behind the hands how old is robin's near
yeah
it's going to get real personal
that's my theory yeah i don't know i
could be crazy
and gay but either way i got i got one
more one more mints just popped into my
head mints
it's uh
i'm gonna [ __ ] it up but he says uh you
know the other day me and my wife's
anniversary 10 year anniversary and uh
she looks just like i told her she just
looks just like the day i met her i met
her at a halloween party she went as a
disgusting old woman
oh man he had a joke about the the
everybody had a not everybody but a lot
of people had a sleeper joke where you
jerk off with your hand because it's
numb yeah so it feels like someone else
called the sleeper but his was the best
one but i'm putting this guy giving him
homework here sorry peters
but yeah dan mintz underrated great
jokes yeah two of my faces
now i've won this i'll give you one more
favorite domara joke oh hey i love
damore ray
he goes i'm gonna mess the joke up but
he's like you ever seen when people find
out someone's gay they act like they
died
they're like get out of he's gay i was
just with him
geraldo had that great joke uh because
he looks so
caucasian i guess but he's colombian
he's like straight colombian yeah and
they would whenever they found out he
was hispanic they would always react in
a weird way like
you're hispanic you look good
i i literally have that one a joke of my
act was i used to bartend south staten
island everyone figures i'm italian
uh-huh
literally this happened to me a guy at
my bar was like sal you're italian right
i said half and he was what's the other
half and i said uh puerto rican and
cuban he goes oh
that's okay that's okay that's okay it's
like i thought it was until this moment
that's hilarious got another one i love
i know we're just rattling off bits
please
he i hate love a bit about how uh
comedians will say true story after a
bit he goes who cares tell it's funny
you know like
like anyone's leaving the show and
that's
stung but boy did he have intense
integrity
i love that
well you mentioned the news earlier it
made me think of that old a tell joke
back when it tell was clean by the way
yeah and he had that joke where he's
like you know the mafia runs this town
they should do the news you know uh hey
bob johnson's gonna die tomorrow
and the tag was uh the winning lottery
numbers are yeah yeah i remember that
salvatory wins again
[Laughter]
brilliant [ __ ]
jokes man love jokes love jokes too bad
those went away
any uh any peas from either of you
oh i got tons of peeves give me a peeve
i have i already have it like
traffic sweat the common cold strong
wind bugs cats pointy objects
and littering you're very wow you're
very scared of kohl's i know you're the
guy who told me years ago apple cider
vinegar yeah every day yeah it'll change
your life come on yeah it's appetite
suppressant secure old google it cure
all swear to god my dad takes a shot of
it every day for like 40 years i just i
mean if i get aids i take an apple cider
i'm good yeah i swear
might be something there all right all
right i'll tell you it it uh it promotes
uh good gut health gut health is a
hundred people there's a hundred things
it does fermented foods are apparently
very good for your brain hey this is
fermented
yes not great for the brain but i mean
apparently kimchi is very good for the
brain
did you see they went after aquafina
what happened uh
oh being black yeah yeah yeah i'm
telling you everybody if you want to
chop somebody now we're all in the chop
i just think it's like you get that
famous you're on the cutting board yeah
you know like they're just that's
another thing that got ruined fame was
great sinatra was hitting people with a
[ __ ]
glass kid got kidnapped kid got cat
kidnapped it was fine he's back at the
uh the arena singing in my life you know
or that's life your kid gets kidnapped
yeah he breaks it up to junior pull that
up yeah what was that what happened i
got him back but it was it was a rant
ransom that's it no and they paid it
yeah yeah i mean
he couldn't get the guy didn't get
arrested it was all on the up and up
no they got the guy they got the guy i
think there were two of them yeah
how old was he
i think who frank was like 30 years old
no he was 19.
out of his hotel room in lake tahoe at
gunpoint i threw him in the trunk like
old school for 240 000
by the way they probably could have been
like it's sinatra's kid we can do a
little better what yeah what year was
that 63 can we do a 240 000 for
inflation it's probably at least
at least a mill now it's got to be right
a million was a lot of money i mean this
is 1960 that's right that's cash in a
duffel isn't it he's not wiring that no
that's that's all cash he's got to break
open the sheetrock tonight yeah
whoa whoa two mil oh it's two
millimeters that's a half 2.2 mil okay i
was way off so wow
so it's damn god damn it
wow inflation is no joke so it's uh i
guess that is 60 years ago
and he paid it
yeah of course
he paid that out of his pocket
and then and then and you know
i remember reading the book i forgot
what happened what what is it was weird
there was a weird motive there it was
more than just money people don't do
that anymore right no people don't send
ransom notes or ask for a duffel of
money or anything like that no isn't
that what the is that with the people
who kidnapped or who shot lady gaga's
dog walker were trying to do they were
trying to do that yeah i have no idea
what you're talking about oh see this is
why everybody shot lady gaga
they snagged him he's her dog yeah she
has two very high-end kind of she-she
dogs that are worth a ton of money
purebred oh she saved the dog they took
the they dog napped oh and he said the
dog walker no no he was the the victim
of these guys dogs got stolen yeah
purebred when when
this is about a year ago yeah really i
missed it
oh did they shoot him yeah they shot him
dude did he die i think he survived but
he's not well i don't know i think it's
like a i mean he got shot a few times
damn he's the 50 cent of dog walkers
did she did she take care of the guy did
we know how she yeah she did she did she
really gave him a lot of money i would
hope yeah oh there he is like he's he's
revealing the uh the gun show oh my god
oh he's kind of shredded not bad he
seems
fine seems all right i got you come out
of that okay are you like actually i'm
glad it happened i don't know dude he
might have some like nerve damage or
something yeah you never know what he
got it on video oh my gosh this is why
you can't kidnap oh
no
are you is this
oh that's good look i'm not gonna lie if
i had to kidnap a dog pretty i mean why
did they shoot him he did he fight back
i would have been like take the [ __ ]
no
i think he fought back a little take the
thing got to be careful someone's got a
gun do not fight back
that's good advice that's my wreck of
the week
don't fight back if you were in a bad
way a bad way
do you think you could turn not to a
life of crime but do you think
your circumstances are pure you don't
intend to hurt anybody yeah but do you
think you could do something like that i
couldn't shoot somebody but you don't
know where your next meal is coming from
you got a family oh he's got you there
and look we're not we're not women we
can't do only fans
you're lucky ladies that's
i lost money
good teacher really seems to care
you know do you see do you say you know
what i know i gotta i got a tip a hot
tip that's lady gaga's french bulldog i
don't want to hurt him at all i'm gonna
swipe him i'll make you know
do you do you go there i don't think i
don't think i have the constitution oh
no way but i'd like to think i could be
a likable con but i don't think i have
it in me that would be cool like a
matchstick man yeah
danny ocean we all would like to be
clooney or matt uh brad pitt or whatever
every con movie the the khan gets conned
and then there's another con it's like
it's like five cons like everybody slow
down this isn't how it goes
like everyone's con and ever they're
ahead of the con
kind of and then their head
then they're ahead of the con comp of
the second con well have you seen the
tinder swindle step ahead no it's all
gone
what do you mean hot jewish guy from
israel is conning all these hot blondes
he's going he's he's whining and dining
him he's loaded
but he's not actually loaded he's using
money from other ladies so he's getting
laid he's [ __ ] all these blondes and
then he's going off on jets in uh lake
como and all this [ __ ] but how is he
doing this yeah because he goes uh hey
uh lady i've been [ __ ] for six weeks
i'm a rich guy but
i'm in the the diamond business and
we're getting under attack right now by
the whatever hamas
can you give me they froze all my cards
can you give me like 20 grand and then
he does that to like six women i mean
now he's up to you know 500 grand
whatever the hell it is joe millionaire
of the show on steroids what's that i
don't know though you don't know joe
millionaires where they say he's a rich
guy but he's not really rich no if he's
not no that's the whole hook of the show
so he shows up and he's like you know in
a yacht or comes buying a horse or
something but he's a construction worker
so when they fall for someone at the end
he tells him guess what i love you you
felt me but i'm broke yeah
and then they stay on which is so [ __ ]
up um obviously but then we did it and
now one of them is rich and the other
ones
i've never i i saw like one episode of
the original but i mean it's well the
beauty of the uh the tindler swindler
tinder swindler is all these people are
like well ladies if you weren't so
greedy
which you know it's [ __ ] up because
you still stole from them but like
it's kind of fun because these hot
ladies have been using their looks he's
using his fake money to get ladies
well what's the difference between a
lady that uses her
that uses
that uses her moxie or whatever it is to
get to vagina yeah
that's one way to put it but yeah she's
a guy she's a hustler yeah he's hustling
but that's common biology yeah i i don't
know if i have empathy for those women
you're six weeks in on a tinder date and
you're giving someone twenty thousand
who owns a diamond but i mean it's like
you gotta i mean you've got a few messed
up motives right you're doing this in
the hopes that you're getting money back
he must be a really good lover
i wonder if he's got a great personality
he does and most con men do and they
show the text you're like this guy's
[ __ ] smooth and he's on a private jet
going i miss you baby and then he hangs
up the phone he picks up another phone i
miss you baby and it's still like 20
different women it's pretty wild i know
there's a lot of jail
there's a lot of anti-semitism in the
world because i heard that
why does he have to be a [ __ ] jew
yeah and he's he's all in he's diamond
he's israel i mean he looks like a
complete douche well the lady's like a
douche they'll deny those glasses though
look at these women he's pulling oh wow
oh wow
wow and these ladies like wow i want to
go wait they're on tinder
get on this thing good boy
i have never been on a dating app maybe
it was raya but i want to see his
profile cause i want to know what like
how ostentatious was he because if he's
putting out some pretty materialistic
photos then i do judge them a little bit
for swiping
of course they're all they're all in the
bentley with the diamond rolex flip it
and reverse it did you meet that woman
you're dating that foot she's [ __ ]
your brains out yeah yeah i wouldn't buy
it i didn't know why
she's a dream woman yeah three months
you you're you're you're head over heels
yeah she asked you for money you're
gonna cut a check no
i don't think i would either but dumb
guys will i mean they've been just been
happy i used to watch jenny jones or
ricky lake and they'd be like yeah i'd
take men's money and do some hot blonde
and and everybody's like yeah yeah he
gave me a bentley what are you gonna do
i'm hot
and so this has been happening since the
dawn of time but now i think dudes are
figuring out how to do it wow
not saying it's right
again for the record just saying
and this is a picture of him with all
different women yeah so is he in jail he
got caught like stealing money i think
he's in jail can we see can we see his
profile pics matt i want to see you
can't find it i guarantee you his tinder
profile has been screen capped and put
up online it's gotta be oh yeah
i forgot his name now it was live oh is
that him in custody is that him in cuffs
in the blue looks like it
he looks good in cuffs though the the
sunglasses oh he's all sunglasses he's a
lens crafter
it does look like justin silver a little
bit yeah it does but see he's got the
designer the armani shirts and
everything
uh what's [ __ ] up was this feels this
is how
morally bankrupt we're talking about
these awful shows but couldn't you just
picture this being a show on netflix
where you're like the tinder swindler i
know it takes your money and then
they're like all right we're giving you
the money back i think you want better
pitch that [ __ ] yeah pitch it yeah pitch
it the thief hell look at uh west elm
caleb you guys heard that story what's
that oh
this is a guy
this is a guy in new york city who's
banging all these cougars and he works
at west elm
and
west oh caleb and he keeps i was
wondering if it had to do with the
furniture so when you said it of course
you've got to be [ __ ] me and he
there's israel west elm he's this hot 25
year old guy he works at west elm so
these women come in to buy [ __ ] these
single divorcees and he's [ __ ] all of
them and then they found out that he was
[ __ ] all of them and they're all
pissed oh my god is he giving them a
deal no no no maybe a deal hey you want
this end table you got to blow me but
where's tom caleb funniest moniker i've
ever heard oh i know
you may know me look i want to get this
out of the way right now i had a i had a
pass
[Laughter]
i
uh you ever hear west elm caleb yeah
he's big designer at west elm maybe he's
a designer caleb how many discounts on
ottomans do you need this month yeah
he's got good bro he definitely does
that what do you call when you do the
eyebrows
ooh uh waxing no i didn't do the
threading you ever do that i heard it
hurt no i know don't act like you were
looking at mark and not me for that one
right
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure because i see them
sometimes and they are they're
miraculous oh they're beautiful you guys
are nice freed my mind i know i'm
touched see that might not touch it i
think they're balding now they're very
light i don't have the i don't have the
dark brown
i don't know the dark brown i used to
well if you're gonna go ball that's the
place to do it yeah yeah my legs are
bold really yeah my dad my dad has all
of his hair he's 76 he didn't go uh gray
until his little very very very late 60s
like zabalt
huh i'm hoping i think i'm under the
same same scenario that's crazy though
i'm telling you right now i don't have a
hair on my legs we're going gray now
yeah yeah need to ankle a lot of hair on
my legs
yeah is that new it was it was it was
over time but right now people are like
what do you swear
and i'm like did you look above the
knees because i'm not a swimmer that's
for sure that's strange yeah but i'd
rather go bold on the legs yeah of
course you know
interesting wait you were saying what
about your eyebrows oh i just feel like
if i were to do it it would it it
worries me when when you put too much
work into that yeah yeah i feel like it
would look like it's like a weird it's
like very jersey shores sure for sure oh
yeah you don't want a manicure like that
no no no no you're gruff
yeah gruff is good you're clothing yeah
what are they yeah
you have a baseful voice thank you you
you have some height on you you're tall
talking handsome weak yes
yeah hey uh so we we might be drunk are
we getting
good i'm already done i need another one
we got another show after this just
saying oh [ __ ] okay who's going on next
for christchurch
[Laughter]
if he comes we got to block a week off i
gotta say i do watch all your podca
derosa's been on the podcast before okay
i love your podcast with darosa it's the
one with chris or hilarious the derosa
one gets so uh taste buds it's called it
gets so heated you get so heated uh and
so i was watching a bunch before you
came in here today and i just wrote down
some of your takes you're a skittles guy
uh well skittles went up against who he
went at sour patch kids right are you
like skittles better over sour patch i
don't do sour you are you skittles too
yeah sour patch yeah why i told him why
do i have to get through a
candy
you went nachos over sushi i wrote down
oh that's crazy that's the staten island
india right there yeah i can't go nut
because i can make nachos at home i
can't i can't do that with sushi if i
had to not eat one for the rest of my
life i don't know i think but nachos is
a wild card every time i don't know what
i'm getting every time i order it that's
true but same with sushi same with sushi
the most organized food on the planet no
but you don't know if you could go to a
bad place you're in trouble what are you
talking about the buckies where are you
are you getting sushi here i'll tell you
i won't walk into a sushi place unless i
yelp it or google it first okay that's
fair but yeah
but these are like episode six yeah we
were more passionate we are passionate
now but there was like the first like 30
or 40 minutes of the try i'm like you
like this i hate that i hate that and
then we would fight it's not hard to
fight him you know he fights immediately
yeah he does yeah what's the most heated
argument
oh man cookies versus cake oh cookies
for some i remember we would i got i
almost i got purple screaming at him
the first thing is it started we were on
vacation and he told me a cinnamon
raisin bagel is better than everything
that's insane and i and i and i we went
we were fighting for three days i don't
know and then i said this could be a
bond this is your vacation
we got drunk one night i don't know what
we were doing it was something you and i
yeah me and you got hammered and we were
at the stand underground it was all
closed up and you're shit-faced
breathing all over me going i got two
pods ideas
and i was like oh yeah yeah you know
everybody says that and he's like juan
with derosa i'm like he's still doing it
we talk about food i'm like oh yeah
great
we're both blacked out like leaning on
each other like the other one's called
hey babe i'm like oh hey bail that'll be
great
but i remember you telling me these
two years ago three years ago yeah they
came to fruition they were a long time
coming then the pandemic hit and i was
like no about a time yeah exactly yeah
yeah the fights with food uh are are
great you wanted to do something that
was mindless you know yeah yeah well the
country's fighting about everything at
least now at least now they're fighting
about something yeah we wanted to apply
the passion to nothing yeah that's
brilliant yeah
i love him sour patch come on what's a
controversial food opinion you have
controversial yeah that one we all have
something we hate that everybody loves i
don't know i'm trying to well is there
anything you love that everyone hates or
something you hate that everyone loves i
i gotta i mean at this point we've done
like seven months what do you got
i think it's overrated everybody's like
this changes everything bacon it's fine
bacon's fine oh babe you put bacon on my
dad's dick i'll blow him up like all
right bacon we did bacon versus sausage
i took bacon i did win
you one with bacon it's more total it's
more versatile i'll give you that have
you ever had chocolate covered bacon no
what is that it's like a speed ball try
they do a little chili in there a little
spice it's too like the canadians do the
chocolate potato chips too it's a
i like anything in chocolate it's pretty
good it is good but it's like my thing
with uh bacon i'm
that i'm with you i hated in the early
aughts when bacon was someone's entire
personality yes when they're just like i
like bacon and you're like yeah everyone
does yeah i like it but it's not a it's
not a godsend
i agree yeah i get a turkey club
you're looking forward to that bacon
it's an accent you get you get a little
bacon in your salad you're looking
you're looking for pieces of bacon sure
sure no i got something there was one i
hated and i got flipped on it what oh
pear
you hate a pear i did i love a pear i
i'm telling you guys in the minority
really not a lot of people i like pizza
i know people buy and eat pears no i
don't know i don't buy them so where do
you get them my mom used to grow them oh
my god again i'm from but i asked i
asked i asked my whole crew this on i
said who here buys and eats pears here's
the problem
two people raise their hand a pair it's
like a jewish person you might get a bad
one you know no i'm joking but a pair
it's like sometimes it's mealy and well
i don't have a good pair you gotta have
a good never have it but a good pair
will change your life well that's what
happened i had a good paradise and i
said i literally have to admit right now
i was wrong i didn't know these pairs
exist yeah you want it okay it's the
opposite of a woman if it's too wet it's
a disaster
and with this weight gain you got a
solid pair
it isn't ironic i became the pan
i am shaped i i found a fruit that i
never knew existed before last year and
it is my favorite of all time don't tell
me
passion dragon no pomegranate no
it's it's a it's a it's a
a strain of actual of a popular fruit
mandarin orange what do you call
clementine no
peach it's a certain peach a certain
piece like it's like the charlie murphy
of the peach it is
i bit into it and i literally just i
would
whoever was closest to me able to punch
him right in the mouth wait what kind of
thing i couldn't believe what i was
tasting it was a taste explosion saturn
peach chatter and horrible car
doesn't even exist anymore look up a
saturn peach it's hard to get in season
if you get it in season you bite into it
i promise you it's like indiana it will
change fruit it will change fruit i've
never even seen a saturn peas
on this where do you get one nor did i i
found them at trader joe's oh
trader joe's not known for the
not known for their produce i will say
right i got two times that were they
were fast they were unbelievable and
then the next five times i tried to
recreate it they were god awful i think
it's true i think it's about getting
them right in the right
sweet season well wait a minute is it
does that have the fuzz like a peach the
peach fuzz
because that fuzz is a bummer to me it
is a little you get through the fuzz and
you say it's magic yeah i didn't really
see fuzz but i mean don't all peaches
have fuzz oh no yeah that's why i don't
love the fud too much fuzz is bad you
don't want it no it wasn't too much fun
it was a good amount of fun what about
uh okay i got one for you my a
controversial food take for me
just overrated i don't dislike it but
it's just overwhelming okay i can't wait
mac and cheese oh
i just find it to be over if look if you
make a lot of bad mac and cheese that's
the problem mac and cheese i'll tell you
on the podcast is a powerhouse there's a
certain powerhouse this is up there with
like pizza and stuff fried chicken
things like that but i think pizza's
never bad it can be not as good as
normal i've had bad pizza i guess you
can have bad but bad pizza is better
than bad mac and cheese to me bad magnet
cheek to be bland
carb all day carbs overload and bland
i'm getting the worst of both worlds
here i just don't if you look if you do
one of those special mac and cheeses
there's breadcrumbs in there if it's
like one of those jalapenos the balls
off i'm into it some fried shrimp in
that shirt you got a shell a nice shell
with a nice golden crunchy top crunchy
as you cut it out like with the spatula
now we're talking you just
yes but i do find that i've had a lot of
bad mac and cheese in my desk another
personality i'm a mac and cheese girl
they have restaurants dedicated to mac
and cheese they don't serve anything
else and you're like come on branch out
live your life it's so it's it's a basic
[ __ ] thing mac and cheese yeah it is
yeah you're right but i get it but there
is great mac and cheese but you're right
i think it's a little overblown a little
overblown a lot a lot of uh well now
we're talking like not like actual
product like actual product placement
but we do also do like
like actual sold on shelf products and a
lot of those have taken a hit in quality
over the years now one of our first
things that was really controversial was
oreo versus chips ahoy
wait what
who takes chips ahoy over oreo thank you
sir what are you saying mark aye chip's
ahoy oh you're insane all day what are
you guys oreo oreo oreo's
yeah dude chips ahoy has fallen off hard
oh i haven't had it they're smaller
there's less chips they're really cooked
they taste like chemicals now oh i think
oreo were chemical the whole time oh
look how many oreos this day oreo is
like heroin bro yeah look at look how
many jobs oreo has given to people we've
got the lemon cream we've got the the
golden oreo is [ __ ] good dude i don't
know what that is
oreo's in everything it's oreo this oreo
that
people borrow oreo to put nest their
[ __ ] oreo for a topping on ice cream i
just find it hard to beat uh you ever
had a soft batch
that's keebler yeah i had a soft package
i just you can't beat a chocolate chip
oreo is a classic dude well it wasn't
chocolate chip it's not chocolate chip
it's oreo versus chips all right all
right all right all right that's a great
chocolate chip cookie no one's denying
the power okay it might be my favorite
thing here's another yes fresh
controversial
i got another controversial take
oatmeal raisin love mmm i like oatmeal
good oatmeal raisin cookie is outrageous
outrageous it's outrageous but you don't
have them often they're not that great
when they're packaged that's if you're
going through a bakery or you're getting
like a little upscale one yeah now
you're in the right look suffers from a
similar problem to the mac and cheese
which i brought up earlier so yeah
grandma makes mac and cheese oreo i mean
um uh what's the other thing cookie chip
soy no oh
yeah grandma makes oatmeal cookie or mac
and cheese it's in store makes it not in
yeah fair enough it's gonna be made with
love so we've branched off a little bit
to not just food battles so we do like
other things too now but we're taking
we're gonna start a powerhouse
tournament regardless of what you are
jews versus palestine
something like that all right let me ask
you mark has to work with one every week
so i know he's going to be against
[Laughter]
we might be doing uh a battle of the
titans
pizza oh that's like the olympics versus
yeah
christmas
whoa
well you know what it's a pay-per-view
event it's a pay-per-view event
you know
this isn't easy i'm going pizza all day
i don't i don't have christmas 40 nights
a year
oh good point
you're saying you would sacrifice yeah i
would christmas for pizza look christmas
does a lot of good and i'm not going to
deny that people look forward to
christmas it's an important day do we
lose christmas movies
christmas is gone
the whole thing is going christmas
forever you got to pick one
none of your childhood christmases exist
none of the magic
none of the nostalgia no you're not
hurting me now
oh oh the the day i went to watch the
next
a couple of chinese foods yeah come on
all right i mean look
even as a jew i have to admit i love
christmas i even like christmas music
it's me too i like i love it i know you
guys don't get people who don't like
music i don't get people who don't like
it i'm lighting these christmas candles
now i get crazy i get crazy when there's
too much christmas music like by the end
by like late december i'm like alright
i'm out but when it starts creeping in
like you know november i'm like well i'm
into this i'm november 1st yeah and i'll
tell you another thing i don't shy away
from like just throwing one on mid-year
damn yeah i'll listen to that you know
in the [ __ ] summer you'll throw a
jingle all the way in june i'll do it
damn i don't want the bar i worked i
used to throw a christmas in july party
wow
oh man that's like being nice
what's that nothing nothing what did you
say
that's like being nice to blackfield in
march february's over all right now
uh but again
christmas and pizza i feel like you're
jumping the shark here these are two
different worlds it's hard to argue
that's what it is okay okay you see
which side which side are both are you
taking
it's going to be in a tournament so i'm
not sure yet i'm not sure yet i gotta be
honest i don't know what i would do
there i don't know what i would do pizza
is everyone's favorite food christmas is
my favorite holiday well it's it's that
uh dave attell joke hey i can't remember
the setup but the punch line is well
it's all your favorite things about if
you name a boat
pizza pizza [ __ ] christmas santa yeah
there you go is that what he said pizza
[ __ ] santa yeah pizza [ __ ] because
everyone likes one of those things
[Laughter]
here you know be a fun idea for your
show and feel free to kick me in the
balls here i've been drinking japanese
whiskey but
you get two
high
profile lawyers
and give them a thing and then you and
joe team up and you guys debate with
lawyers because you guys are proud
reverse them us first down i love that
you guys are two brilliant arguers
now you got two professional arguers
make a case against these lawyers
who used to be lawyers so you got dan
adam and ella bell up in that hey good
oh good call wow i think dimitri was a
lawyer we haven't had many guests we've
only had a couple because i'm i film it
out in staten island and we don't have
the room but we're actually branching
out now so we're bringing in all guests
we're doing three ways four ways team
ups all that [ __ ] now if you guys want
to team up against two right here yeah
it could be what we might be i would
love to have you on we'll go to the
island you guys want to do it yeah you
should take that ferry over there i love
the fair i'm right by there it's not far
by the way jost is doing a fairy show i
did it first oh yeah you did on fallon
tonight show yeah yeah
i did uh during the pandemic i had a
fallon
waiting you know they're like hey you're
gonna do foul and covet hits so i was
like i still want that fallon i still
want that too but it was gonna be a zoom
so i didn't do it i didn't want to do
zoom either so i said
all right you got to be outside shooting
outside sucks let's at least make it
interesting i got my guys my camera crew
we shot a set on the staten island ferry
so we're outdoors what we're on a ferry
it's different it was great you just did
it gorilla oh they let you you probably
i did a gorilla and they took it no one
on the ferry came up to you and said you
can't do this
uh they did after but we got it we got
it in the can you got we also brought a
drone the dro the wind took the drone
right into the sea and it hurt it cut uh
dominic's hand right that's right yeah
yeah ladies and gentlemen
filmed it and dominic uh mull who did my
roof thing that he did the uh drone and
he did that for mark's thing too yep and
the propeller from the drone cut his
hand bad no way yes that's right where
did you set the mic up you did it
outside inside we brought a big uh
speaker it was just mike cord to speaker
and we got a couple fairy goers and i
got a couple fans out there and they
just stood there in the freezing cold
outside outside on the back end of the
boat where you get off to get on you're
[ __ ] me and did you do the set from
manhattan to staten island manhattan we
did it from manhattan to statin to run
it and then we got it back and then so
you only had people that were on you
happen to have just people that were
commuting on that phone i had about six
people who were fan i just wrote a tweet
like hey this is a crazy thing i know
it's ridiculous but come on out how many
people were watching probably about 12
that's it that's and you put that on
fallon yeah they bought it
was there enough of a feedback like well
we we've cleaned the sound up like a
[ __ ] so
and uh here it is like like dude i had
no idea nobody's at least at least show
a bit man that's pretty cool wow
the sound isn't great but this is it
looks beautiful island ferry in new york
city you're [ __ ] me that win was so
crazy
this is good times good to be here they
played this version on fallon with the
win that's the economy there they are
people
anything it was like the wild western
yeah they're all here because some guy
made love to a bat
speaking of battles
shut down the production of the movie
batman because batman got corona which
doesn't shock me too much because the
wrong part of his face is covered
that like the dock is like the light you
gotta just like look back and go [ __ ] i
gotta wrap this up
exactly exactly but a bunch of like uh
fairy guys like doc guys were like
watching me from the top level like ugh
and that was totally in my head the
whole time where'd you get that and you
had to do that huh how did you get like
you just thought of it thought of it
because i knew i wanted to it had to be
outside because they were so covet
strict and i was like outside outside
how do we make this in the roof and so i
said new york comedy club can i do it on
the roof and they said someone already
did that and then i said what about this
now what about the top of the empire
state building no fairy would you boom
the audience or would you do it yeah
big boom wow and that played on fallon
yeah nobody cared i was like this is
gonna change it's like a green sketch
holy [ __ ] nobody gave a [ __ ]
that's so cool yeah it was fun
yeah yeah now they get they got that
ferry i don't know how that's gonna i
don't know how you're gonna put in tens
and tens and tens and tens of millions
of dollars to turn that around i know i
spoke about it so colin jost and pete
davidson bought a boat i don't i don't
get why
i i i mean you know if you're from
staten island like it was so i saw
someone sent me the link that it was
going to be on for sale
and i thought i didn't know i didn't
realize it was a oh it's for sale i
didn't realize
there it is i didn't realize it was
gonna be an auction it said in the thing
125.
and you don't understand like that is
that's low like like that that the ferry
to me is like it's like church yeah it
really is it's like it's it really is
it's steeped in in who i am you know
it's like i have so so for 125 to own a
and and by the way it was the john f
kennedy jfk i took that boat every
single day really yeah every day for a
decade like more so i was like wow
that's not
that's not too much now i didn't know
what the implications were for making a
purchase like that yeah and i got that
text on a monday i texted two friends
and i said
should we buy this i didn't know for
what i said should we just buy it i
don't know what we got to find out what
the holding costs are but at 125 if we
don't you know if it's a good finance or
whatever the hell it is and figure out
what to do i don't know what we're going
to do with it and then a couple two less
than 48 hours later they they
i wouldn't but i'm glad i didn't and you
buy a ferry together
right what does that mean i'm sure
somebody i guess paul italia bid on it
for colin p or whatever and they just i
don't know what they worked out but
they're gonna they have plans for it
they i talked to colin he they just did
it blindly like so he doesn't even know
the holding costs
we kind of made a snap judgment he goes
i think it's gonna be a losing
proposition maybe but but we're gonna
really we're gonna really work on it get
invested try to dock it and try to make
it into something i think it's a really
cool idea great cool that they're both
staten island guys i love it i love it
that's huge yeah but it's so cool and
but but yeah and i was like i you know i
might have been
i might have gone in on that if i was in
the conversation but in hindsight i'm
glad that i didn't it it it is uh going
to be a tough that's a lot of money yeah
a little bit to dock it to repair it to
all that stuff so but in theory it was
great and i wish them well but i like
i'm not good i'm probably glad i didn't
do it yeah no it's gonna be a headache
but i think the demand to go just the
idea the novelty of it i think will
bring people out yeah you know hey a
stand-up show on a boat it's pretty i
mean
right i would do it in a second i've
done it yeah yeah why not so i like that
pete and uh colin are going for it yeah
let's try something crazy but
i think it will be tough to keep we'll
see where it goes sustain yeah yeah and
maybe in like thirty things will buy
subway cars or something that would be
like yeah let's move yeah
i get this homeless guy jacking off my
that's mine i own that
yeah it holds over 5 000 people almost
just
just spruce it up dock it and throw
events
yes so i'm sure they'll do what's the
move though this is an old boat they're
still doing the ferry obviously yeah all
right all right ferry's 24 7 365 free
it used to be a quarter used to be a
quarter 50 cents token when did that go
away a long time ago okay also no cars
anymore since 9 11. that's when it
changed that's pretty recent yeah 911 it
was cars every oh well there was boats
that handled cars and boats that didn't
ah i got you i love that growing up it
was just we pulled our car right on that
ship wow
amazing if you think about it yeah we
just lined up pulled our car on then
pulled out in manhattan that's amazing
wow it seems like so far and now but but
i remember that oh i mean was my i mean
i was only 20 years i i was in my
mid-20s that we did that wow yeah and
now it's like and it's like it's you
know it's crazy it's like i don't know
what nine i guess it's like
yeah you're like okay we're exposed here
there's a risk if you uh someone brings
a car but you know after that it was
like anything can happen but it's like
the guy who lit his shoes
one guy lit his shoes failed no more
shoes 30 30 years globally no more shoes
it's like it's wild he fails well i know
but all you have to do is sign up for
clear or pre-check and you you get
around that but like yeah i'm a monster
which i am thank god yeah i mean that
[ __ ]
i see people taking shoes off now and
i'm like sucker like i i really like the
people that don't have easy pass it's
crazy right well i've had friends who
are like i don't want to be on the grid
i'm like you're that dude that dude is
making your life less comfortable just
you be on the grip i mean what do you
gotta but don't you worry that the
government is saying hey we're gonna set
this rule unless you pay
so they're not really worried about us
they're like give us the money and we'll
let you keep your shoes on because you
got to pay for clear yeah
are you guys clear as a private business
i know but i'm just saying it proves
that they don't actually give a [ __ ]
about you if they're like all right pay
a couple bucks well i think i think the
idea is that you're vetted
you check your fingerprints they they do
it they do a background check yeah
well you did for tsa free maybe not but
for pre you did well what happened was
tsa pre was the jam i did the thing and
then all of a sudden tsa pre-the lines
were out the door so they had to come up
with something else
right given more yeah you got it i love
it it's the only way clear has saved my
ass your role
it's what it's a couple hundred bucks
whatever it is if it saves your ass once
it's it's paid for it think about how
much more we're gonna have to give up in
like 10 years like what i don't know
what the next line there's gonna be a
third line everyone's gonna have clear
we're gonna have to they're gonna be
like do a dance and we're like you gotta
do a dance if you wanna get the third
one like oh you're in the foreskin line
yeah
it's good i've asked your guys uh travel
recently with covenant [ __ ] been my
travel has been nightmarish i've had the
worst luck i've had lucky knock on wood
really i have seven or eight flights in
a row that were cancelled
in a row over three multiples always
united well that's a problem they cancel
i can't believe the airline that
suffocated a puppy in the overhead
yeah it's [ __ ] up they're the worst
uh always united lost my luggage damn
what does that have to do with covington
i stick delta for the most part and i've
been pretty lucky good delta's good
champ blue's pretty good
sleeper one i just southwest is a
sleeper they were sleeper but they
[ __ ] uh
it's shady it's a little too egalitarian
for me you think so i don't socialist
yeah i like what's this i took your
advice oh hell yeah dude love it what do
you got there well i was uh i would say
i'll take a frontier whatever i got i
finally got this this tin don't put that
up on that oh okay i'm sorry
[Laughter]
can you blow that man yeah all right
it's a sky miles car because i want that
lounge [ __ ] the lounge is big
yeah especially on delays yes yeah a
little little another hack if you don't
know have you got an amex
business amex
[Laughter]
you got a platinum business amex you get
in lounge free yeah
yeah and and if you have two of them
right like just order another one they
send it to you free
and then give you have one in the pocket
you give to your friend they never check
the name you just show it you get in oh
wow you could order another one and
they'll send it to you in the mail you
have two they both work wow you just use
one to get to your friend to get into
the labs for free otherwise you gotta
pay uh you gotta pay yeah yeah i'm gonna
do it the united lounge by the way which
i've gotten into it many times not great
nah kind of a waste it's like ramen
noodles and handy snacks and cheese
doodles and you're like what are we
doing we're like in a time machine when
i was 12. yeah exactly
yeah i went into the virgin atlantic
lounge in in london oh the
internationals can i tell you something
i've never seen anything it was like a
it was the most i wanted to stay yeah
they had full private full
private bathrooms with showers wow
they had a lounge with a pool table wow
they had a tv movie area oh they had a
menu
that they give you to bring you food not
go up and serve yourself
it was lights out i was like i cannot
believe what i'm looking at there's a
woman high-speed wi-fi
[Laughter]
yeah if you ever have it i only did it
once but it was like
i mean it was a real experience
yeah i did the lounge and uh i did the
melbourne comedy fest and they hooked
you up with business class
the lounge was incredible it's like you
said i want to leave and the flight was
amazing it's a 24-hour flight or 20 and
you were you were in lay flat uh i was
in lay flat but i didn't need it i mean
i had a i had non-stop scotch the food
was amazing you got food anytime you
wanted to sleep on that right you could
sleep like you could you could go back
pretty good but it was just
beautiful i didn't want it to end
yeah it helps and now let me tell you
something i went to australia once i
never thought i would go i can't sustain
a flight like that it's a nightmare i
saved up i spent i got business class it
was 7 500 tickets
i tell you this the flight was full it
was direct from la i went to la then
direct i got on the flight i get to my
seat my [ __ ] seat is broken
[Music]
this piece right here was like it was
velcroed on i sat and it sunk all the
way in it was like there was no um there
was no like give on it like there was no
support yeah it fell all the way in i
got up i pulled it off it was a little
flimsy thing with velcro on it and it
was like it was broken so i said whoa we
didn't take off yet yeah so i called the
lady the lady called the guy the guy
came with the neon vest
right and he and he's working on he's
like oh and then he goes yeah i'm sorry
there's nothing we can do about this and
i said to the lady i paid seven thousand
five hundred dollars for this ticket
good for you i bought a lay flat i've
been waiting for this my entire life
my first time to australia you need to
[ __ ] fix this yeah we got a 20 minute
20 hour flight cooking she calls another
couple people and she comes here because
i'm really sorry
i can't fix it what i'll do is i'll give
you two seats
put the seats on top of each other maybe
we just have a little extra support and
i was like i had to go and i was like
you told me this is the only thing so i
folded my hoodie i put it inside the
seat i put two seats on it it still felt
like absolute [ __ ] it didn't stick so it
was like it was like slipping out
24 hours straight you know what she did
she came over in midfield she goes you
know we're really sorry about your
experience so we want to help you in
some way so here you go and she hands me
a [ __ ] just me she hands me a cheap
bottle of [ __ ] champagne oh geez what
do you want me to celebrate here how
[ __ ] shitty this is
no
wow one airline put him on blast uh
the main i don't know it wasn't like the
one like the ones we it was like the
emerald australia no no it wasn't
emirates look it up peters get the
australian line it's not even the
champagne is that it's sparkling apple
juice
we had these like cubby holes to put all
[ __ ] and i just put it in there and left
it there damn you're a good dude i mean
you could have tweeted all day long hey
[ __ ] or whatever i found that
it works against me q-link pelican
hinterland jetstar
nope go back up i think we might have
missed it topan unity nope unity yeah
they're digging a little hard on that
there's a deli in in manhattan called
the united we stand deli and i'm like
settle down
but i found that like i found that if i
use twitter to like get justice i get
[ __ ] on uh i was like just [ __ ] calm
down your [ __ ] celebrity you know
like whatever they say i'm like i'm a
human being that values the dollar yes
you know like you paid that money damn
yeah
yeah i i didn't do it for that but one
time i remember like my night i bought a
pair of nikes nike like tech
[ __ ] pants that were like i splurged
i was like i'm gonna buy it you're a
sneaker guy too i'm a sneaker guy i
bought these they were 210 dollars for
these sweatpants again never purchased a
sweatpant i never purchased a sweatpant
over 50 bucks yeah in my life i put them
on there with thin legs they look good
they were like elevated i could wear
them out i could dress them up a little
bit it was like a utility pair i'm like
i'm going to splurge 2 10 for sweat i
mean that's like paying 500 for crocs
it's wild yeah it's wild but they were
like this technology it was like you
know it was in like the nike flagship
okay i splurged i bought two pair black
and gray and immediately they fell to
[ __ ] they were like [ __ ] and so i i
was like i'm going to tweet them so i i
tweeted i say nike i bought i spent this
money on this thing
and man uh nike shut me down publicly
whoa they were like yeah nope like
literally on twitter and like and then
everybody else was like either was like
uh you [ __ ] spend 200 on sweatpants
you [ __ ] and i'm like well i just i
took a chance guys
i'm i'm middle aged i have no kids i
i've been saving for a while like i've
been saving for a while like let me just
no kids this is all i have yeah i have
no kids so they [ __ ] on me for that and
then they [ __ ] on me for nike [ __ ]
on me wow and that was it i was just
left i got the pants still i i'm shocked
i mean i've [ __ ] on air you can sit on
biden he
apologizes i can't believe you get well
people just think like you know because
you're rich and successful i'm not
really i mean well i guess i don't know
what a tv star yeah i guess so but they
really they really don't like wow but
i'm i am i'm the i'm normal my opinion
on money has not changed a single bill
no i'm just saying single bit why would
it same you know what's happening how
are you raised yeah i'll spend money on
food and that's about it
you know it's i'm pretty bedding
footwear
bedding experiences good sheets are very
important to me mattresses sheets
bed no no bedding big cutaway to
draftkings
literally literally
put money into your bed
yeah because you're in eight hours your
pillows buy a 200 pillow buy a five six
thousand dollar bed but i mean i mean
you know put it on a plan do it if you
can do it yeah like just just do it
they'll they have like interest-free
[ __ ] do it like that
[Laughter]
next time it's like january 6 was pretty
cool
you gotta get a good fill if you're
gonna sleep with the capitals
you are on you got to rest up we got a
storm
you are on your bed one third of your
life yeah well not us put the money in
real the three of us yeah it's true but
yeah that's what i said and you're
standing
this is the first year mark and i have
stayed in nice hotels like you know like
we we no i really do you really it makes
a difference i should i just had this
conversation the road every week mark no
you're right you're right and we're not
even staying in the four seasons we're
just staying in something not shitty
right
my manager sat me down when we really
started like i really started like doing
like
50 60 70 see whatever it is and he was
like you have to because i wouldn't and
he said you have to fly first class he
goes and you have to you have to upgrade
the hotel you got to make it amenable to
you you can't just be grinding and then
get on the plane and be uncomfortable
and get there and you get in the room
and it's not good and then you're just
like you hate your life yeah you got to
just oh thank this is great this seat is
great this room is great it'll help and
it'll go a long way and i didn't want to
spend that money but i i changed a few
years ago and it makes all the
difference yeah yeah you can do it if
you can do it you put the time in not
but if you could do it now do it yeah
well you talk to anybody who's a
non-comic any civilian about traveling
and they're like oh i had to go to
newark and then the airport took forever
and then you and i'm like i do that
every week
multiple times a week you psycho
we checked in the hotel they weren't
ready and we had to wait and you're like
yes yes that's my [ __ ] life my life i
remember so many times check getting
there like 10 a.m and they're like your
room won't be ready till three and
you're like cool i'm gonna sleep right
here yeah
yeah exactly exactly right there and you
know they can do stuff for you you know
that it's it's all up to the person what
they're feeling behind every one of
those people behind us has the power to
do whatever they can for you
so you got to go in up top big smile yes
like you don't need nothing like your
room's already ready you go and you say
oh my god you read the tag hello
clarissa how are you today how are you
how are you know how are you yes and
then you smile i'm great at you know
like how's every how's the what you just
make a little small talk and then you'll
see it go
oh
and let's go
you know what it's not ready but i have
this other and it is yeah you're right
you gotta get in i had to say
you could also say clarissa uh your
husband phil and your kid steward i
found out all their names if you don't
make my room work out
bad things can happen i have a set of
unusual skills
whatever he says you go home tonight to
phil had this at cava it was pouring
down rain and i went into cava just to
get out of the rain it was in in wall
street area
is underrated underrated it's like uh
it's like cava c-a-v-a yeah it's like
mediterranean it's like a worldly
chipotle it's more expensive
literally a geographical location
it might be actually there it is that's
cob it's one of these bold places but
it's it's really good it's very good
so i went into cava and i was like all
right i'll buy a bowl i feel bad i was
making jokes like look we're not gonna
lie to you i just want to get out of the
rain and it's a couple of just a couple
of knuckleheads behind the counter and
i'm busting their balls and they give me
a free bowl because they can they don't
they don't care
everybody can everybody can a little
lone secret but how often are you on the
road and you pop in like a like a diner
and you're like oh let's get a coffee
and then you try to pay and they're just
like that'll happen that'll happen
they're like just take it you give them
a little flavor
over the weekend wow i'll tell you
that's all that happened in alabama that
crowd did not like me
it was crap that was the only goodwill i
got that weekend
huntsville you have the best crowd work
clips online oh yeah thank you man
terrific well i record every set so it's
not right every road set at least so
it's you know but uh that uh
that crowd holy [ __ ] they were really
not easy yeah yeah i mean i feel like
there's you were you know it was the
weekend i did you worked yeah
you had to work through every show
thursday was up and down friday
uh
early was really rough they were stiff
late show they were just hammered
saturday early was pretty good and the
late was great but it's like man they
were it was a it was a tougher weekend
than i've had yeah i've been back out
there for a while wow totally
those are those weight club though the
club was very well run and they were it
was just like man
it takes some getting used to and that's
that's okay man like it's okay to
you know not you you make some necessary
edits on those bad weekends i think so i
i'm i'm okay with it you know what it's
kind of like i'm sorry no go back uh
i like to watch these boxing
documentaries
oh yeah and there's always these boxers
that are just dominating they win every
fight and then they go fight some guy
who's tough
and they say like oh [ __ ] it woke me up
and i had to like try and that's with
these bad rooms i was just in syracuse
and it was just like oh you got a you
think you're somebody right we'll bring
you right back down and you got to work
it you got to make it happen it's also
like you're like it's a mall and
seriously i figured i was helping out a
little bit here
i didn't know there was like a hot thing
to do in this town i'm trying to bring a
little joy you bought a ticket and now
you're mad at me it's like the highest
suicide rate in the country can you help
out a little i'm trying to turn things
around for you yeah meet me halfway did
they do that to strippers she's out
there dancing like not feeling it
yeah they did hard oh i don't think a
stripper in syracuse has a great life
yeah that's a tough one it's me and my
friend's birthday
dance to limp biscuit
meanwhile it's it's q up there and
you're like keep dancing q
i'll tell you another little known hack
yeah please i think another little lone
mackie
god bless him one of the funniest guys
in the world
uh
you can ask for a pers like a disc like
a a sale like a percentage off in any
store
if you have the stones wait a minute my
friend used to work in retail he used to
work at nordstrom rack yeah
i love norfolk he was one of the top
sellers east coast wow and he let me
know the inside scoop and when i'm with
him and we go out he'll walk into a
store and he's just got balls and he
just goes up and he goes and he'll ask
for the manager whoever's working i'd be
like hey uh what can you do for me today
whoa swear to god hey
he'll say it out right he goes 10 uh 20
i want the family i want the employee
rate 20 and they'll have they can give
it if they want yeah no there's no
primary looking over it yeah there's no
regulation they can hit whatever button
they want on there and you could ask it
all he asked for it all the time wow
gets it like 2 30 like 75 of the time
and then when sometimes it when he's
with me he goes and i'm going to shop
because what are you going to do for my
friend why i won't say no i won't say it
but he says it and people be like
they're laughing like i i give you 20
damn just off the street
i love it charm man
if you have it i need to ask now here's
my hack about retail i steal it
[Laughter]
mark really does steal it from uniqlo in
soho tell me to swear swear it i swear
to god i saw this on the unicorn i
bought a little like a little slip-up
and i stole this okay take me through it
because i i have a lot of questions now
about you about the process everything
by the way mark the more you admit to
this on podcasts the harder it's going
to be to get out of this when there's a
record you might be right you might be
but go ahead nobody's talking nobody's
going to look no one kills have you seen
rogue no one keeps track of pockets
they're going to beep every time you
stole something
mark's compilation uh
stealing snacks unicorn theft i stole in
context
so you stole from uniqlo 17 times in 14
episodes
it was over years no but i still this is
like i don't know two months
so i knew i needed a little zip up i
lost my my zip up got stolen go in yeah
knowing you were gonna steal no okay i
knew i wanted the jacket like a little
took over like a flea what do you call
those uh puffy things you know puffy
jackets oh like a little patagonia type
deal yeah oh yeah they they have great
ones there they're reasonably priced
exactly yeah that's where i went so i
went on broadway so you didn't go
because it was reasonably priced
uniqlo's got good deals they do so i
went there and they the last one i had
that got stolen by the way karma
i guess they didn't do it okay but uh it
got stolen so i was like i want that one
again that's what i'm trying to steal my
jacket yeah i'm gonna steal a used
jacket right i mean unless you're from
you don't you're homeless you're
stealing a new one that's class
okay so you go in and you're going in
for the puffer
yes all right so i try on some puffs i
try out some puffs and i go you know i
do need a black sweater are you alone
yes continue you got to be alone do you
ever do it with your lady nah cause i
don't want to incriminate her what's up
but you told her you stole that
i told her yeah
she was not turned on i was like
she was like ah you're 38. get a [ __ ]
life weirdo
[Laughter]
okay are you are you as into this as i
am
i mean i've heard it before and i still
do i still like it no i still like it
have you told her on the pot already
well we i stole a shirt last week and i
told him that story but this is a
different shirt mark steele's concert
mark stole a shirt that he wore on conan
that night with the buzzer on it
oh that's legendary thank you thank you
uh oh wow we can pull that up you can't
see the buzzer but it's on there i can
tell you which conan it was but either
way
so i go in i put the buff the puffer on
i'm like this is the one and then you
pass by a sweater like that's a
good-looking sweater oh there's no uh no
no buzzer all right let me try the
sweater on okay it fits then you put the
puffer on over you're like all right
well i'm buying the puffer so here's my
move i go up and buy the puffer with the
sweater on if they catch me i'll go oh
[ __ ] i forgot obviously oh that old that
old well obviously i'm honest because
i'm buying the one
so i'm willing to buy obviously i'm
honestly
yes so if they catch me i will pay for
it and i'll go i'll play dumb well hold
on are are the uh changing rooms on on
on uh supervised well that's usually you
go and they go hey what you know what
your name sometimes they write it and
they say how many you need and they put
the number on it they scholarly right on
there sure well what am i an amateur
okay
sweater on in the hallway i just throw
it i had the sweater on before you went
into the fitting room yeah so it's
pre-meditating no there's no fitting
room i put the sweater on there's a
fitting room i mean i didn't use it
though oh
i put the sweater on in the hallway
whoop one one swipe bam it's on and then
i throw the puffer on i go too brazen to
be
exactly the brazen is the key right yes
and i do this at the airport soccer val
they steal batteries the old people yeah
matt you're gonna have to clip this up
mark's describing stealing in detail is
fantastic
so so so you say
okay when you see it yeah yeah
i want to know the moment you're
deciding this deal the moment once it's
on you it's a lot easier you're like so
before it was on you weren't even
you weren't even connected no i tried it
on i was like i got this i knew i had it
once it was on so you put it on and then
the seed yes was like i don't need to
pay for well there's always a c would
you say you put the jacket on at the
register and you say oh here's the tag i
want to wear it out yeah
and then they go you got to take it off
and i go okay okay and i take the jacket
off and they they beep
no questions asked okay i'm looking at
your shirt right now yeah that's a very
standard shirt so that could be bought
anywhere so i wouldn't know if i was an
employee of uniqlo i wouldn't know if
that was unique exactly
so if you had a basic yeah like a solid
color a basic a layer or a sweater then
no one that's balls if they're going to
because if they take the jacket they
accuse you of stealing you know that
sure i had a i had i had a friend who
used to be security if you accuse
someone of stealing and you detain them
and they haven't stole you got a lawsuit
on your hands oh yeah that's good to
know i didn't know that yeah okay so you
put it on you said i'm not gonna pay
don't [ __ ] how much don't egg him on now
he's going to find a way to see how much
was this sweater this this sweater i
think was like oh that's a stolen one
right there
all right i think it was 40-ish okay and
the puffer was 60. so
is any part of you saying okay the
consequences are not worth 40
or you're saying i feel like bulletproof
it's bulletproof because if they go hey
whoa what's that sweater go oh [ __ ] i'll
pay for this too
then you're out boom in and out wow and
you think you haven't that that's it
you've never gotten caught never never
what do you mean you've net you've never
gotten caught i've done this uh a
thousand times you should see me at
hudson news at newark i'm all over the
road you're kidding no they're cameras
they got cameras
never never had a problem what do you
what do you see them you still i take
dramamine a wrap usually a couple of
hard-boiled eggs and a water and what
are you stealing that's what i'm
stealing what are you paying for no not
that's what stealing is whoa whoa well
here's what i do he's getting
i'll tell you where i'm putting it so i
got this i will say they rape us at the
airport yes so this is a little bit of a
justice though if you buy one newsweek
you're you're fair
so nine dollars for a new yorker yes
thank you
so i got the roller bag i put it all on
top of the rollerblade just right on the
top and i roll out i look around
before you know what i make terminal
three i'm on the flight so looking
around do the look around again i like
that
you do it every time every time you
always need something at the airport you
you walk out with an egg salad sandwich
laying on top of your of your of your of
your carry-on yeah carry-on and you walk
out
wrapped
with other things eggs sitting right on
it and nobody ever say
well you got to think these people are
all behind a counter they got their face
in the register they got their fitness
screen face on the legs about the
cameras well by the time there's some
chooch in a in a camera room
in a newsroom in the top tower i'm
already off the kc cumulatively how much
do you think you start
you'll be in the thousands forget about
it yeah way over there yeah i mean i was
i'm more than 911 cost really oh yeah oh
yeah this is crazy and you and you and
you you're going to do it again you know
that well it's part of my routine now
wow routine
did you ever think about
what happens if you get caught if you
get caught and they don't forgive you
you know what's crazy that's scary it
doesn't matter
right well it doesn't really matter
you're not going to you're not getting
it
you're not going to get knocked out
[ __ ]
company on state because you stole the
[ __ ]
post article that says mark goes down
with that you can see him at the
syracuse funny bone this weekend
he'll use it as a plug
he steals things not material come see
that at the funny box so when you walk
into an airport when's your next when do
you meet me on the road this weekend
this weekend in omaha so you're going to
jfk newark god bless i'm going to new
york i'll see you there all right friday
thursday okay so you're going to new
york you know walking in i'm going out
to news i'm doing my routine
also it's every time this is part of it
and you've and and are you you you are
bad in a thousand yeah i've been caught
in
dozens decades a decade yeah i'll tell
i'll send you a photo
do you feel weird making what you make
and still stealing
no i gotta tell you he said it's all in
there
it's who you are
i am beside myself
because it's it's it's par for the
course it's happening every time you
know you're doing it you always make
that stop unless you're late you're
going to hunt the news yeah and you're
leaving you're stealing stuff yeah i'll
tell you my biggest bounty oh sorry well
i'm going to ask you one question at any
point your heart rate does it it doesn't
spike it oh yeah oh it's spiking does
every time oh yeah of course because i'm
aware being a batting a thousand that
spikes everything yes why would you
please sell truth
part of it it's a lot of people bungee
jump why do people skydive okay so this
is your punch jump yes
but isn't it okay we can continue yeah
so my biggest bounty one time i my
flight got real [ __ ] up and i had to
sleep basically at the airport because i
couldn't find a way and they left these
gates down
they left the gate down here and it had
about a [ __ ] two foot and i
i rolled right under that gate and i was
i was eating dinner in there
it was oh my god it was like the l.a
riots it was like the riot i was looting
i was like the guy of louis vuitton this
is what do you think about this is this
you can you do it have you ever done it
i can't do it i can't steal from an
upstairs i can't steal from a hudson i
can't do it from the place god forbid
someone like i'm on and they grab me
joker goes down
when i was younger i went to a baseball
card show do you remember those oh i
love those baseball i don't know if they
do that were you a collector baseball
when i was i mean when i was in grammar
school yeah i went with my best friend
what's that we got to wrap up soon but i
want to hear this we'll wrap it up all
right i went to a baseball card show i
was wearing a fanny pack it was a short
face it was a short face
i was wearing a fanny pack my one of my
best friends at the time we go in and i
know somehow or another he's deciding to
steal cards i remember it a kirby pocket
tops 85 rookie a dallas strawberry
rookie a dwight good rookie at don
manley rookie a whole bunch of guys that
good taste he's taking him putting him
in my fanny pack i'm not taking him
you're an accomplice yes yeah i'm an
accessory we do the whole lap and then
my dad is scheduled to pick us up so
we're doing the whole lab he's throwing
in my fanny pack i got like a couple
hundred bucks worth of cards for my
fanny back rookie cards out the s we go
to leave when my dad's coming to pick us
up and as soon as we go to leave some
guy gets in front of the doorway and
stands in front of us he goes stop right
there
he goes you're not walking out of here
and at the same exact time my dad was
entering and i saw him walking up and
the guy was holding me and my dad was
like what's the matter here like more
about the guy like why are you even
holding my son like he goes what's going
on and the guy was like well your son's
stealing cards oh so my dad
literally i see him go up shade of like
red he he i was i was
i want to say i was 12.
he takes me by my shirt and lifts me in
the air he thinks he bombing [ __ ] he
goes
is this true he and my dad never hit me
in my whole life he wouldn't even curse
in front of me yeah he kissed me he goes
is this true and i i he goes is this
just he said is this the son i've been
raising ah
and i pissed my pants
i don't blame you piss my pants the guy
you ruined the cards the guy felt so bad
for me the guy felt looked at me in the
air pissing and he was like get out of
here you know and i went home with the
car whoa
my friend went home we lived in the
apartment buildings right next to each
other so your dad was doing it he got no
trouble his parents were like you stupid
ass she got caught he was outside doing
[ __ ] wheelies on his bike my dad
screamed to me i was doing that like
crying thing right and he left the house
i remember i was behind that the
sectional i hid behind it because i was
so scared yeah he's yelling sure he went
out he came back it was dark i was
behind the sectional still he opened the
door turned on lights he saw him back
there and he was like he's like i'm
really sorry about like i yelled at you
like that but you can't do that all
right so that was a fast forward a
couple years later it's christmas time
we're in sears
remember when those wrestlers was wwf
wrestlers those like bendable like those
big wrestlers
wrestling buddies yeah okay so we're in
there and i'm shopping with him and i'm
like dad can i get a wrestle i'm like
i'm i'm coming with you i don't want to
be here so i want to jesse the body
ventura so my dad takes it we get online
at sears it's mayhem there's like a long
line waiting my dad i have to be
somewhere wait wait i see my dad getting
i'm patient and patient and i literally
watch my dad go
and then he breaks open the plastic
takes jessie the body out of the
packaging and he goes uh you know what
let's let's go because i got to be
somewhere let's go and we start walking
toward the door and he has the just the
thing loose in his hand and i'm looking
at him and we get to the vestibule and
we get to the vestibule and i go stop
and he's like well and i go you're going
to take
jesse the body ventura and he goes
it goes i'll come back i'll pay for it
tomorrow i go no
we're not going to steal that i don't
want to steal that what we're not gonna
steal that and he goes he looks at me
and he goes ah you're right we go back
in he gets the packaging we stay online
for like 25 more minutes he pays for it
and i took i took him the task for it
wow
he pissed my pants oh look at that serve
justice cyclical came right back i
thought would have been a great story
end of the uh first stories if the dad
sees you get away with that and he's
like we got a good thing going
yeah we just start conning people you
you pee on command i yell at you we're
taking tops and [ __ ] bowers all
together we've got a honest wagner in
there
wow what a story yeah man well there you
go where are you going to be guys yeah
yeah there's some dates
like you you're may 7th at the beacon
you're at 14. i am may 14th
it was announced today i don't know when
this comes out when does it come out
two weeks so that's it tickets are on
sale right now at the beacon may 14th
i'm at the ryman march 11. wow and um
everywhere else i have like 20 30 cities
up right now
please yes we savilecanoecomedy.com you
man thanks for coming on yeah bring
justice to the body ventura toys i still
have it
oh you're a good son and a horrible dad
where are you gonna be i'm all over the
place tampa cincinnati columbus
louisville fort wayne indianapolis la
jolla i'm in all of those too okay
raleigh
uh chicago this summer it's gonna be
mark normancomedy.com sam we're adding
chicago again uh taping something there
we got
sacramento san diego orlando west palm
columbus salt lake cleveland the beacon
in new york
uh so many cities uh it's all on
samerol.com shows we keep adding [ __ ]
brea toronto uh added a second in
toronto and pumped for that and remember
guys uh we we might be drunkpod.com we
got these glasses now we got all kinds
of [ __ ] we might be drunk at gmail.com
for the patreon stuff we love you
uh keep listening we'll see you soon
hello yeah we love you guys this is a
blast boys thank you for coming sally
great up
[Music]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
be
true
[Music]